all right this is from newsweek uh
coca-cola facing mounting backlash from
conservatives online
has responded to allegations of
anti-white rhetoric after an internal
whistleblower leaked screenshots of
diversity training materials
that encourages staff to try to be less
white by the way
starting here in the very first sentence
you notice how newsweek says that it's
conservatives who are
the the ones who are causing this
backlash over the anti-white racism for
coca-cola now
that's correct it is mostly
conservatives but you see how
readily the media admits that
conservatives are the only ones who care
about racism against white people the
media
will readily accept
in fact is happy to give that issue to
conservatives
on friday it's back to the articles it
says on friday carolyn
baransenko an activist who supports
banning critical race theory shared
images from an internal whistleblower of
the company's online racism training
the slides include included tips to
learners on how to be
less white less arrogant less certain
less defensive less ignorant and more
humble
because of course we know that you know
that's synonymous with white
is being arrogant and all those other
things
now uh so this is the part you probably
heard about all this a coca-cola
spokesperson confirmed that the course
is part of a learning plan to help build
an inclusive workforce but also noted
that quote
the video circulating on social media is
from a publicly available linkedin
learning series and is not a focus
of our company's curriculum they said
our better together global learning
curriculum is part of a learning plan to
help build an inclusive workforce
it is comprised of a number of short
vignettes each a few minutes long
the training includes access to linkedin
learning on a variety of topics
including on diversity equity
and inclusion okay so that's uh that's
your classic non-denial
denial um because they're saying
they're not coming out and saying this
is totally made up and photoshopped it's
not real
they're saying yeah this is part of the
curriculum it's just that's not our
focus we're not focused on that part of
it
well if we want to know whether that
excuse should wash then all we have to
do is like i always say
with something like this if you want to
know whether it's racist and if it's not
immediately clear to you like something
like this should be
all you have to do is take white out and
put
another race in so if coca-cola
was putting their employees through a
training course
that at any point included the
instruction to
be less black there would be
no controversy at all this would we we
wouldn't be calling this a controversy
there'd be nothing like that
around just everybody would agree
across all aisles would agree that it's
uh that it's
inexcusable racism and it's racism by
the way
just straightforward racism because the
other thing that i've seen in response
to this um
coca-cola story is uh the claim that
this is reverse racism
in fact there are still some i think
most conservatives have
have wised up on this issue but
there are still some conservatives that
i've seen saying this is reverse racism
coca-cola's committing reverse racism
no this is not reverse racism let's be
clear about that
coca-cola is not guilty of reverse
racism they are guilty of
racism straightforward regular old
racism
there's no such thing as reverse racism
there's just racism
that's it reverse racism implies
when you say reverse racism you are
you're surrendering the point you're
seeding ground
you're agreeing with the left's premise
that racism itself
is a white thing and that white
white people own racism and so if a
black person or if a non-white person is
racist
they are all they're doing is reversing
the racism
which has a hint the phrase itself has a
hint of kind of
giving them a taste of their own
medicine right
well we're just we're reversing the
racism back on you
there's no race that owns racism racism
is racism reverse racism not a thing
this is simply racism listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated